Uh, thank God comedian, because they say things that if I was a politician,
my race would end immediately all the time. No matter what. Um,
but it's all good. You can't even be Johnny Depp nowadays.
Johnny Depp can't even do it guys. Turn it. What happened at Johnny Depp?
Everyone hates him. All of a sudden, all of a sudden everyone's like,
you know what, actually, Johnny Depp,
everyone loved Johnny Depp. He was like the guy.
And then all of a sudden, everyone was like, you know what? Nah,
why? Cause he dressed like an Indian a few times. What happened?
White guy can't dress like an Indian anymore. Nope. Can't
you see that? Your ad? Um,
the is a Christian Dior. Is that what it was? Uh, whatever it was
Johnny Depp is canceled. Right? So it's all good.
Cancel. Culture's crazy, man.
You mother are cancels. That's what I'm going to start calling you.
I don't know if that's probably a thing already, but your counselors,
Johnny Depp, your ad pulled a mid cultural appropriation outcry.
It's crazy. These buckled to these, these peeps. You know what?
It should just be. You know what?
It should just be that ads should just be full polled because it's stupid.
How about that? Have you seen it? He's dressed like a.
You're not Indian. Uh, you know what I mean?
Johnny Depp railing on the, what is he doing?
Even do your survive.
That's a CAC to call it salvage.
Like don't have two earrings in one ear. Hey,
is your ear one ear? Is it two ears?
Johnny Depp,
digging a hole and burying a necklace and putting all his jewelry in
there under a rock. Hey,
that's not the Dr. Johnny. Depp's insane period. That's it.
But why do we hate him? He doesn't know.
He's been famous since he was three.
See, here's the thing.
Cultural appropriation and cancel culture. Cancel culture was.
People.
Well, you had it, man. You had it right there. You had it right there.
It was on and popping dude.
We did too much, uh, guys and.
They did too much. And they were, and they were,
they were on top for too long and they were boring as.
And they were abusing their power. And then the people were like, you know what?
That ain't cool.
And everyone started to listen because they were right because they were right.
All this me too, all this cancel culture, all this cultural propagation.
Everyone was like, you know what? Maybe these people have a point. Maybe,
maybe everyone else has a point. Maybe white guys were on top for too long.
And they just got to, you know, big for their britches.
And then what happened was you were like the hot ch you know what?
You were like the hot chick that we just started dating,
that the world just started dating. You were the hot chick. And you were like,
God, look at this girl, walking into this cafe.
Look at them. Look at them, you know, all the, the, the,
the dudes were look at them, look at them, dead fish, look at a thin waist.
Look at a backside. He goes on for days. And we were listening to you, dude,
because you walked in and you were the most bang in his chick ever.
You would like to check that all of a sudden turned like 21, 22,
that everyone was starting to pay attention,
to figuring out how to do her makeup. And we're like, wow.
And we started dating. You cancel culture.
We started dating the out of you dude. And about three,
four or five months in which is, you know,
a year in whatever the you want to say it. He realized, Holy, man,
you're a lot. You're a lot to deal with.
And you're complaining way too much.
And that's what happened. And then we started to get, okay, you know what?
We were, we were having sex. We were laying you out. And it was funny.
Having romantic dinners, learning about you, dude,
we were learning about you canceled culture and we were on your
side and you just did take it back. I don't want this.
It's not good enough. We, you, you did that one too many times.
You went, I don't like the temperature one too many times.
And then all of a sudden we were like, you know what? We can't win.
it. Johnny Depp. Can't wear turquoise now. it.
You can't, we can't win. If we can't, when we're out, if we can't win,
we wash our hands.
I've said this before. We don't care what you buy.
I don't care what you believe in, believe in what you want to believe in.
But you can't. I care about the way you believe in it.
That's the thing. You were the hot chick that was banging. You had it all,
all you had to do was pick the right to complain about.
You know, it's fine to walk into a guy's place for the first time and be like,
Oh, you keep the couch over. Here we go.
We're blinded by Teddy's. Yeah. Maybe the couch would,
maybe the couch would look better. Yeah. I, uh, okay.
Maybe the couch you have the wrong, the end,
the table should be not in the middle of the two couches.
It should be on the end of the couches.
And you should L the couch so you can watch the bachelor with me better. Uh,
yeah. Oh yeah. I guess I didn't.
What were the windows where we had it like that?
Because when guys come over for game night, we use the table to,
but I guess you're right though. What are you saying instead of,
I guess you're right though in real life is blinded by
Teddy's. Yeah.
The couch should be an L shape because of your waistline.
Ah, see, that's the thing, dude.
And then what happened was you could just move the couch too much,
dude. And now when you say something's cultural appropriation,
or if you say, you know,
I sucked at and T Aziz Ansari's Dick and it was.
We go like this, Hey dude, I liked the couch.
The other way.
I liked the end table on the end of the
couch. I don't like it. I like it.
I like it separating the two couches.
So now we're going back to playing game that you go ahead.
If Johnny Depp can't wear turquoise, then we're going back to game night, man.
You could be banging his face, but everyone gets tired of the relationship, man.
So be careful what you complain about. That's it? That's it.
When you start saying, you know, ah, Chris Hardwick did this though.
And then the, and then Chris Parker is where I got the text messages right here.
This is the proof. Oh, we're back to playing game night, man. Now,
do I know enough about those situations now? I don't.
Is it okay to talk about what I'm talking about? Maybe am I comedian? Yeah.
So does it really matter? No, cancel me.
I don't know whatever it's like, believe what you want,
but once you hit that, you know,
the pendulum you're up for everyone who actually really does have a problem.
And that's it. And that's all I have to say about that side of the, Nora.